happening right now hundreds of workers
with the culinary union gathered right
outside of southern nevada health
district demanding them to step in and
investigate possible violations
regarding room cleaning victoria saha
joining us live from that rally on
decatur near us 95.
brian this rally started about a half an
hour ago but dozens started gathering
much earlier they say this rally isn't
against the southern nevada health
district but they want them to look into
some of the issues they are concerned
about most members of the union present
at this rally are room attendants for
various properties on the las vegas
strip they say there have been
violations of the senate bill 4 which
requires hotels in clark and washoe
county to provide daily room cleaning
and bans hotels from discouraging guests
to accept daily room cleaning culinary
union members say they have recently
been asked to clean their rooms only
after a guest checks out but room
attendants like diana thomas say they
want to make sure rooms are always
thoroughly cleaned
[Music]
they're not doing what they're supposed
to do and we're here to make them do
that as far as the cleanliness of the
rooms every day and we need to have that
done every day not just every other day
we need it done every day because of the
cobit
the culinary union says they sent worker
statements to the southern nevada health
district regarding this issue the health
district says they are aware of the
rally tonight and that they always
respond to complaints but they have
still yet to receive complaints from the
culinary union reporting near the
southern nevada health district tonight
victoria saha live local now